last time we created a kubernetes
cluster and set up the new stack driver
monitoring and logging on it today we're
gonna set up alerting
to let us know if there are any issues
with our application running in that
cluster this is the stack doctor
[Music]
what can we do to get an early heads-up
that something's going wrong well the
first thing to do is to figure out what
our service level indicators or slis
should be and then have stackdriver let
us know if and when our application
might be in danger of violating the
service level objectives or s ellos will
define you may be thinking wait
SLI what's that well an SLI is the
metric we'll measure and use as a proxy
for user happiness for our service
running on our G key cluster we're
primarily going to care about two things
latency and availability we'll want to
know if and when either of those drops
below our desire thresholds but how the
great news is that stackdriver gives us
an easy way to do what we want with
alerting policies let's set one up for
availability now but first what should
we use as our SLI the first option is
pretty straightforward
we simply have the application output
all errors to standard out or standard
error which will then show up in
stackdriver logging automatically we can
then configure a log based metrics from
those that'll tell us how many errors or
failures we're seeing and we can use
that as our SLI another option would be
to use a proper instrumentation approach
with something like open senses we won't
get into the details of that library
here but you can watch Morgan do a great
deep dive on it we'll post a link to
that in the description our third option
to consider is Prometheus it's a leading
open source monitoring tool and the good
news is that the beta version
stackdriver monitoring for kubernetes
supports it just install Prometheus into
your cluster and you get to go export
metrics in your application and the
Prometheus exporter will ship them right
into the stack traver back-end so those
are our three options log metrics open
census and Prometheus no matter which
one you choose you will have metrics you
can use to represent availability let's
do that now we can create an alerting
policy using the G RPC completed our PCs
metric to let us know when we get more
failures than we allocate an error
budget for and we're done I should know
that while error rate is a great service
level indicator this alerting policy is
not a true service level objective it
doesn't have a good way to represent
what percentage of overall calls are
failing which is what would really need
that is provided by the service
monitoring functionality and stackdriver
which we'll cover in a future video now
that we've got availability covered
let's take care of our latency SLI as
with availability there's more than one
way to measure application latency we
can use load balancer logs and
instrumentation library like open census
or even logging from the application
itself as before let's start by creating
an alerting policy we'll select an open
census latency metric as our condition
and put a response time threshold on it
and there we go we've now got our
application running in kubernetes and
instrumented for monitoring and
stackdriver is gonna tell us if anything
goes wrong that impacts latency our
availability when something happens that
causes our availability or latency to
fall below the thresholds we've defined
beside driver we'll create an incident
that incident can also be used to
trigger notifications like email
messages integrations with other alert
management systems or even webhook calls
to trigger remediation actions if we
want when the application is a restore
to a healthy state through some
corrective actions like rolling back a
breaking change the incident will be
resolved come back next time when we
take a deeper look at troubleshooting
latency issues with stack driver trace
that's it for this episode this is the
stack doctor stay healthy out there
[Music]